willkommen zurück bei „Quanteninformation und -berechnung verstehen" – mein Name ist John Watrous und ich bin technischer Direktor für Bildung bei IBM
Quantum. Dies ist die 10. Lektion der Serie und die zweite Lektion in der dritten Einheit, die sich mit der allgemeinen
Formulierung der Quanteninformation beschäftigt. Diese Lektion handelt von Kanälen, die Veränderungen in
Systemen darstellen, die Quanteninformation speichern. Dazu gehören nützliche Operationen wie die, die von
unitären Gates und Quantum circuits durchgeführt werden, sowie Veränderungen, die wir lieber vermeiden würden, wie Rauschen. Wir können auch Messungen
als Kanäle beschreiben, und das werden wir in der nächsten Lektion behandeln. Der Begriff Kanal stammt aus der
Informationstheorie, die unter anderem die informationsübertragende Kapazität von verrauschten Kommunikations-
kanälen untersucht. Wenn wir also über Kanäle nachdenken, denken wir abstrakt über Kommunikations-
kanäle nach. Es mag merkwürdig erscheinen, eine komplizierte Berechnung als Kommunikationskanal zu betrachten, aber wir brauchen ein
Wort, das den allgemeinen Begriff eines Prozesses bezeichnet, der Information auf irgendeine Weise verändert – und zum Glück oder Unglück hat sich das Wort
Kanal durchgesetzt, zweifellos zum großen Teil aufgrund des enormen Einflusses, den die Informationstheorie und insbesondere die
Arbeit von Claude Shannon in den 1940er Jahren auf Quanteninformation und -berechnung hatte. Hier ist ein Überblick über die
Lektion: Wir beginnen mit den Grundlagen, einschließlich der Definition, was ein Kanal ist, sowie der Frage, wie unitäre Operationen in der vereinfachten Formulierung
der Quanteninformation als Kanäle beschrieben werden können. Wir werden auch darüber sprechen, dass konvexe Kombinationen von Kanälen wieder Kanäle sind – und falls du dich fragst,
warum dieser Begriff der Konvexität immer wieder auftaucht: weil er wirklich ein grundlegend wichtiger mathematischer Begriff in der Theorie der
Quanteninformation ist. Wir werden auch einige Beispiele von Kanälen sehen, insbesondere qubit-Kanäle, die im weiteren Verlauf
der Lektion immer wieder vorkommen werden. Im zweiten Teil der Lektion werden wir über drei verschiedene Wege sprechen, wie wir Kanäle
mathematisch darstellen können – insbesondere über Stinespring-Darstellungen, Kraus-Darstellungen und Choi-
Darstellungen, die nach drei Personen benannt sind, deren Arbeit bei der Entwicklung dieser verschiedenen Darstellungen wichtig war. Im dritten und
letzten Teil der Lektion werden wir einen mathematischen Beweis besprechen, der zeigt, dass diese drei Darstellungen tatsächlich äquivalent sind, sowie die Tatsache, dass sie
alle die Definition dessen, was ein Kanal ist, korrekt charakterisieren. Es ist meiner Meinung nach ein wirklich eleganter mathematischer Beweis und wird hoffentlich etwas
Klarheit über diese verschiedenen Darstellungen bringen – wie sie zusammenhängen und wie sie im Allgemeinen funktionieren. Wir beginnen mit den Grundlagen und
gehen der Frage nach: Was sind Kanäle? Wie ich am Anfang der Lektion schon angedeutet habe, beschreiben Kanäle Veränderungen –
genauer gesagt diskrete zeitliche Veränderungen in Systemen, die Quanteninformation speichern. Wenn wir hier von einer diskreten zeitlichen
Veränderung sprechen, meinen wir einfach eine Veränderung, die zwischen zwei verschiedenen Zeitpunkten stattfindet – im Gegensatz zu einem
kontinuierlichen Prozess, der zum Beispiel über infinitesimal kleine Zeiträume betrachtet werden kann. Kanäle umfassen nützliche Operationen wie
unitäre Operationen, die von Quantum Gates und circuits durchgeführt werden, sowie Veränderungen durch Rauschen. Für die
Zwecke dieser Lektion werden wir jedoch hauptsächlich Kanäle in abstrakten mathematischen Begriffen betrachten, und es wird keine besondere Notwendigkeit geben,
zwischen nützlich und nicht nützlich zu unterscheiden. Typische Bezeichnungen für Kanäle sind die griechischen Großbuchstaben Phi,
Psi und Xi, und wir werden verschiedene Buchstaben verwenden, um auf bestimmte Kanäle zu verweisen. In einer einfachen Situation, in der
wir ein System haben, dessen Zustand durch eine Dichtematrix Rho beschrieben wird, und wir einen Kanal Phi auf dieses System anwenden, ist das
Ergebnis ein System, dessen Zustand durch die Dichtematrix Phi von Rho beschrieben wird. Wir betrachten einen gegebenen
Kanal Phi also als eine Funktion, die auf Dichtematrizen einer bestimmten Größe – oder mit anderen Worten
auf Dichtematrizen eines bestimmten Systems – angewendet werden kann, auf das wir diesen Kanal anwenden. Es gibt einige Anforderungen, die Kanäle erfüllen müssen, um als
gültige Kanäle zu gelten. Erstens sind Kanäle lineare Abbildungen. Das ist vollständig analog zu der Situation, die wir sowohl
in der vereinfachten Formulierung der Quanteninformation haben, wo Operationen auf Quantenzustandsvektoren notwendigerweise linear sind,
als auch in der Standardformulierung der klassischen Information, wo probabilistische Operationen linear sind. Du könntest diese grundlegende
Anforderung der Linearität infrage stellen, wenn du das wirklich möchtest. Aber wenn wir eine Theorie haben wollen, die sowohl mit der Wahrscheinlichkeitstheorie
als auch mit der Entscheidung, Quantenzustände durch Dichtematrizen darzustellen, konsistent ist, dann haben wir keine Wahl und müssen akzeptieren, dass Kanäle linear sind.
Die zweite Anforderung ist, dass Kanäle Dichtematrizen in Dichtematrizen überführen. Das macht vollkommen Sinn, denn wenn wir uns entschieden haben,
Zustände von Systemen durch Dichtematrizen darzustellen, und wir einen Kanal auf ein System in einem bestimmten Zustand anwenden, muss das Ergebnis ein gültiger Zustand und damit
durch eine Dichtematrix dargestellt sein. Es gibt jedoch einen sehr wichtigen Zusatz: Diese Anforderung
muss nicht nur gelten, wenn wir einen Kanal auf ein isoliertes System anwenden, dessen Zustand durch eine Dichtematrix beschrieben wird,
sondern auch, wenn wir ein zusammengesetztes System haben, dessen Zustand durch eine Dichtematrix beschrieben wird, und wir den Kanal nur auf
einen Teil dieses Systems anwenden. Das sind also die Anforderungen, die wir an Kanäle stellen, und wir sehen, dass sie den
Anforderungen für Operationen sowohl in der vereinfachten Formulierung der Quanteninformation als auch in der Standardformulierung
der klassischen Information sehr ähnlich sind. In der vereinfachten Formulierung der Quanteninformation werden Operationen durch unitäre Matrizen dargestellt, da sie
genau den linearen Abbildungen entsprechen, die Quantenzustandsvektoren stets in Quantenzustandsvektoren überführen, für ein
gegebenes System. Und ähnlich werden probabilistische Operationen durch stochastische Matrizen dargestellt, da das diejenigen sind, die
Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektoren stets in Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektoren überführen. Hier arbeiten wir mit Dichtematrizen und es gibt
diese zusätzliche Anforderung bezüglich zusammengesetzter Systeme, die sich für Quantenzustandsvektoren
oder Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektoren als nicht notwendig herausstellt. Ansonsten sind die Anforderungen analog und werden uns gewissermaßen durch die Entscheidung
aufgezwungen, Quantenzustände durch Dichtematrizen darzustellen. Hier sind einige weitere Details zu Kanälen, einschließlich einer Konvention
dafür, wie wir die Eingangs- und Ausgangssysteme eines Kanals in der gesamten Lektion betrachten werden, sowie einige weitere Details
zur Anforderung, dass Kanäle Dichtematrizen stets in Dichtematrizen überführen. Zunächst wird für jeden Kanal angenommen,
dass er ein Eingangssystem und ein Ausgangssystem hat. Wir können diese Systeme beliebig benennen, aber in der gesamten
Lektion werde ich den Namen X für das Eingangssystem und den Namen Y für das Ausgangssystem verwenden. Konzeptionell gesehen überführt der Kanal
das Eingangssystem in das Ausgangssystem, sodass Eingangs- und Ausgangssystem nie gleichzeitig existieren. Wir
beginnen mit X, der Kanal wird angewendet oder ausgeführt, und das Ergebnis ist, dass X in Y überführt wurde, dessen Zustand durch
die mit dem Kanal verbundene lineare Abbildung bestimmt wird. Die Eingangs- und Ausgangssysteme eines Kanals müssen nicht dieselben sein, und insbesondere
müssen sie nicht die gleiche Anzahl klassischer Zustände haben. Es kann jedoch sein, dass Eingangs- und Ausgangssystem tatsächlich dasselbe System sind, oder mit anderen Worten
Wörter x gleich y, wobei wir uns einfach vorstellen, dass fi den Zustand des Systems verändert, und tatsächlich ist das
sehr oft die Situation, die uns interessiert, aber diese Möglichkeit ist mit dem ersten Aufzählungspunkt insofern vereinbar, als wir nie die
Eingangs- und Ausgangssysteme als zwei separate Systeme zur gleichen Zeit haben, und in jedem Fall wird es praktisch sein für
die Zwecke dieser Lektion, verschiedene Buchstaben, nämlich X und Y, zu verwenden, um auf die Eingangs- und Ausgangssysteme zu verweisen
nur um die Übersicht zu behalten. Gehen wir nun etwas mehr ins Detail über die Anforderung, dass Channels immer Dichte-
matrizen in Dichtemtrizen transformieren. Angenommen, wir führen ein neues System Z in das Bild ein. Lass
uns dem klassischen Zustandsraum dieses neuen Systems den Namen Gamma geben. Stell dir nun vor, dass wir ein neues zusammengesetztes System ZX bilden,
das aus dem neuen System zusammen mit dem Eingangssystem X eines Channels fi besteht, und angenommen, dieses zusammengesetzte System befindet sich
in einem Zustand, der durch eine Dichtematrix Rho beschrieben wird. Das kann ein beliebiger Quantenzustand dieses Paares sein, aber welcher Zustand es
auch ist, es ist immer möglich, die Dichtematrix Rho in der Form auszudrücken, die auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird, wobei sowohl A als auch B
über den klassischen Zustandsraum Gamma laufen und jedes Rho AB eine Matrix ist, deren Zeilen und Spalten dem entsprechen, was auch immer
der klassische Zustandsraum von X ist, und wir müssen diesem klassischen Zustandsraum zu diesem Zeitpunkt keinen Namen geben. Nur zur Klarstellung: jedes Rho AB ist nicht notwendigerweise eine
Dichtematrix für sich, aber die gesamte Matrix Rho ist notwendigerweise eine Dichtematrix. Wenn wir den Channel fi auf
das System X anwenden, wird es in Y transformiert, und wir haben also das Paar ZY übrig, und die Art, wie wir den
Zustand dieses Paares nach dem Anwenden von fi nur auf X bestimmen, ist, die lineare Abbildung fi auf jede der Matrizen Rho A auszuwerten.
Eine andere Möglichkeit, dies zu sagen, ist, dass wir das Tensorprodukt der Abbildung fi mit der Identitätsabbildung auf quadratischen Matrizen nehmen, die Zeilen und Spalten haben,
die Gamma entsprechen, und das wiederum entspricht dem Nichtstun an diesem neuen System Z, aber das ist eine äquivalente
Beschreibung, und es ist nicht nötig, auf Details über Tensorprodukte von Abbildungen dieser Form einzugehen. Sie
funktionieren jedoch auf eine ziemlich unkomplizierte Weise, die analog zu der Art und Weise ist, wie sie für Vektoren und Matrizen funktionieren. Eine Möglichkeit, dies visuell zu betrachten, ist
in Form von Blockmatrizen, und wenn wir die vereinfachende Annahme treffen, dass der klassische Zustandsraum Gamma aus den
ganzen Zahlen zwischen 0 und N minus eins für eine positive ganze Zahl M besteht, dann wird es einfach, all das aufzuschreiben, wie
hier gezeigt. Und um die Anforderung zu wiederholen, die wir an fi stellen, damit es ein gültiger Channel ist: wir müssen immer eine Dichte-
matrix aus diesem Prozess erhalten, und das muss unabhängig davon gelten, welche Wahl wir für das System Z treffen, sowie der
Wahl, die wir für Rho treffen, vorausgesetzt, es ist eine Dichtematrix. Das mag wie eine ziemlich strenge Anforderung erscheinen, und es
mag auch schwierig zu überprüfen erscheinen, aber wie wir bis zum Ende der Lektion sehen werden, ist es eigentlich gar nicht so streng
oder schwierig zu überprüfen, und insbesondere haben wir für diese Bedingung schöne mathematische Charakterisierungen,
die mit den verschiedenen Darstellungen verbunden sind, über die wir später in der Lektion sprechen werden. Sehen wir uns nun einige Beispiele von Channels an,
beginnend mit einer ganzen Kategorie von Channels, die unitäre Channels genannt werden. Einfach ausgedrückt sind das unitäre
Operationen, genau wie wir sie in der vereinfachten Formulierung der Quanteninformation haben, betrachtet als Channels. Genauer gesagt: angenommen, U ist eine unitäre
Matrix, die eine unitäre Operation auf einem System X darstellt. In der vereinfachten Formulierung der Quanten-
information würden wir diese Matrix mit einem gegebenen Quantenzustandsvektor multiplizieren, um die Wirkung zu bestimmen, die diese Operation auf diesen Quantenzustand hat. Die
Art, wie das für Dichtemtrizen funktioniert, ist, dass wir die Dichtematrix links mit U und rechts mit U
Dagger multiplizieren. In mathematischen Begriffen bezeichnen wir diese Operation als Konjugation durch die Matrix U. Das ist konsistent mit KSI
BraSi, der Dichtematrix, die den durch den Quantenzustandsvektor s dargestellten Zustand beschreibt, und es ist ziemlich
einfach zu überprüfen, dass wenn wir insbesondere U auf den Quantenzustandsvektor Ki anwenden würden, wir U mal Ki erhalten würden, und dessen
Dichtematrixdarstellung durch diesen Vektor mal dessen konjugiert-transponiertem gegeben ist, was U mal Ki mal BraSai mal U
Dagger ist, wenn wir die konjugiert-Transponierte von U mal Ki auswerten. Die Art, wie dieser Channel definiert ist,
macht also für reine Zustände Sinn, und wenn wir das mit der Linearität verbinden, sehen wir, dass es für Dichtemtrizen im
Allgemeinen Sinn macht, da jede Dichtematrix als Konvexkombination reiner Zustände ausgedrückt werden kann. Diese
Definition liefert uns immer einen gültigen Channel für jede Wahl einer unitären Operation u. Insbesondere verändert die Konjugation durch
eine unitäre Matrix die Spur einer Matrix nicht, und wenn wir eine beliebige positiv semidefinite
Matrix mit irgendeiner Matrix konjugieren, erhalten wir eine weitere positiv semidefinite Matrix, und das lässt sich ziemlich einfach direkt
aus der Definition positiv semidefiniter Matrizen ableiten. Dichtemtrizen werden also immer auf Dichtemtrizen abgebildet,
und all das gilt auch dann, wenn wir U mit der Identitätsmatrix beliebiger Größe tensorieren, was äquivalent ist
damit, diesen Channel nur auf einen Teil eines zusammengesetzten Systems anzuwenden. Hier ist ein wirklich einfaches Beispiel für einen unitären Channel: angenommen, wir
nehmen U selbst als die Identitätsmatrix. Das ist ganz offensichtlich ein gültiger Channel, der Identitäts-Channel. Nichts
zu tun ist sicherlich eine lineare Operation, und wenn wir mit einer Dichtematrix beginnen und nichts daran tun, bleibt es
immer noch eine Dichtematrix. Das ist also ein gültiger Channel. Menschen verwenden verschiedene Symbole, um diesen Channel zu bezeichnen.
Manchmal ist es genau dasselbe Symbol, das wir für die Identitätsmatrix verwenden, was etwas verwirrend sein kann, aber im Allgemeinen ist es das nicht. Hier verwende ich die
Buchstaben ID, kurz für Identität, nur um Verwirrung zu vermeiden, und diese Notation ist auch ziemlich gebräuchlich. Es mag wie ein
sehr langweiliger Channel erscheinen, aber im Kontext der Informationsübertragung ist er tatsächlich ein perfekter Channel, bei dem der
Empfänger genau das erhält, was der Sender sendet, was in diesem Kontext typischerweise das ist, was man am meisten möchte. Eine andere Art, wie wir
viele Beispiele von Channels erhalten können, ist, Konvexkombinationen von Channels zu nehmen, oder mit anderen Worten, sie zu mitteln,
und die Tatsache, dass wir das tun können, ist ein wichtiger Aspekt von Channels. Um das genauer zu erklären, beginnen wir mit zwei Channels F0 und F1, sagen wir,
zusammen mit einer reellen Zahl P zwischen 0 und eins, und nur zur Klarstellung: wir gehen davon aus, dass diese beiden Channels das
gleiche Eingangssystem, nämlich X, sowie das gleiche Ausgangssystem, nämlich Y, haben. Und nun überlegen wir, was passiert, wenn wir uns entscheiden,
den ersten Channel F0 mit Wahrscheinlichkeit p anzuwenden, und ansonsten mit der verbleibenden Wahrscheinlichkeit 1 minus p wenden wir
den zweiten Channel F1 an. Zum Beispiel wählen wir vielleicht zufällig ein Bit mit diesen Wahrscheinlichkeiten und verwenden dann dieses zufällige
Bit, um zu bestimmen, welchen Channel wir anwenden. Dadurch wenden wir effektiv einen neuen Channel an, den wir Sai nennen könnten,
der durch eine Konvexkombination der beiden Channels gegeben ist, mit denen wir begonnen haben, und den wir so ausdrücken können, wie es
auf dem Bildschirm geschrieben steht. Wir können übrigens immer Linearkombinationen linearer Abbildungen auf diese Weise nehmen, und die Art, wie eine lineare
Kombination linearer Abbildungen für eine gegebene Eingabe definiert ist, ist, dass wir einfach dieselbe Linearkombination der Ausgaben nehmen.
das mag trivial erscheinen, aber es ergibt Sinn – die Ausgabe, die wir aus diesem hypothetischen Szenario erhalten, ist einfach der
gewichtete Durchschnitt der Ausgaben, die wir aus den beiden ursprünglichen Kanälen erhalten würden. Dennoch ist dies ein neuer Kanal, und
wenn ph0 und 51 tatsächlich gültige Kanäle wären, dann ist auch dieses neue Mapping sicher ein gültiger Kanal. Eine andere Art, das
in mathematischen Begriffen auszudrücken, ist, dass die Menge aller Kanäle von einem gegebenen Eingabesystem zu einem gegebenen Ausgabesystem
konvex ist, und das ist eine wichtige mathematische Eigenschaft von Kanälen. Wir können das allgemeiner machen: Wenn wir M Kanäle 5 0 bis f m minus eins haben,
zusammen mit dem Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor, der uns sagt, wie hoch die Wahrscheinlichkeit für jeden Kanal ist, erhalten wir einen neuen Kanal, indem wir die Kanäle entsprechend mitteln. Also
ist das in gewisser Hinsicht eine endlose Quelle neuer Kanäle. Zum Beispiel ist die Klasse der sogenannten gemischten unitären Kanäle das, was
wir erhalten, wenn wir Konvexkombinationen unitärer Kanäle bilden. Das heißt, wenn wir M unitäre Matrizen u0 bis u m minus
eins haben, alle von der gleichen Größe, zusammen mit dem Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor, und wir den gewichteten Durchschnitt der Kanäle
der einzelnen unitären Matrizen nehmen, wie hier auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt, erhalten wir einen Kanal. Und Kanäle,
die sich so schreiben lassen, nennt man gemischte unitäre Kanäle. Nicht jeder Kanal ist ein gemischter unitärer Kanal – wir können nicht
jeden Kanal auf diese Weise erhalten, aber sie kommen sehr häufig vor. Als nächstes schauen wir uns einige spezifische
Beispiele von Kanälen an. Das sind alles Beispiele von Kanälen von einem qubit zu einem qubit, die als qubit-
Kanäle bezeichnet werden. Das erste Beispiel heißt qubit-Reset-Kanal, und die Idee ist, dass dieser Kanal ein qubit
auf den Nullzustand zurücksetzt. Hier verwenden wir den griechischen Großbuchstaben Lambda, um diesen Kanal zu bezeichnen. Die Art, wie du dir merken kannst, was dieser Kanal macht, ist,
an die Bloch-Sphäre zu denken. Das große Lambda sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein nach oben zeigender Pfeil, und der Nullzustand befindet sich oben auf der Bloch-Sphäre, als ob
es auf die Position der Ausgabe zeigt. In mathematischen Begriffen ist Lambda von rho definiert als die Spur von rho mal |0><0|. Also
wenn wir es auf eine beliebige Dichtematrix rho anwenden, erhalten wir den Nullzustand als Dichtematrix. Es ist naheliegend zu fragen,
warum wir die Spur brauchen – könnten wir nicht einfach Lambda von rho als |0><0| ohne die Spur von rho davor definieren?
Die Antwort auf diese Frage ist nein: Kanäle müssen lineare Abbildungen sein, und es wäre nicht linear, wenn wir die Spur von rho entfernen würden. Behalte außerdem im Hinterkopf, dass
wir manchmal wissen müssen, wie ein Kanal als lineare Abbildung auf Nicht-Dichtematrix-Eingaben funktioniert. Zum Beispiel, wenn wir
wie zuvor gesehen herausfinden wollen, was ein Kanal macht, wenn wir ihn auf ein zusammengesetztes System anwenden, müssen wir
diesen Kanal auf die einzelnen Blöcke einer größeren Blockmatrix anwenden. Und obwohl die gesamte Blockmatrix eine
Dichtematrix sein kann, sind die einzelnen Blöcke es im Allgemeinen nicht. Schauen wir uns also genau an, was dieser Kanal macht, wenn wir ihn
auf nur einen Teil eines zusammengesetzten Systems anwenden – und genauer gesagt, was er macht, wenn wir ihn auf eines von zwei qubits anwenden, die
ein ebit bilden. Genau gesagt, nehmen wir an, A und B sind qubits, die als Paar im Φ+-Bell-Zustand sind, und wir wenden Lambda
auf das erste qubit A an. Um herauszufinden, was passiert, drücken wir zunächst den Φ+-Zustand als Dichtematrix aus, und
für dieses Beispiel verwenden wir die Dirac-Notation. Hier ist der Φ+-Zustand als Quantenzustandsvektor, und hier ist das Ergebnis, wenn wir
diesen Vektor mit seinem konjugiert-transponierten multiplizieren und alles ausschreiben. Wir können dann den Kanal auf das erste qubit anwenden und auswerten, was wir erhalten. Hier ist
Lambda, angewendet auf das erste qubit, und hier ist das Ergebnis, wenn wir jeden der Terme auswerten. Die Spur von |0><0| ist eins,
und die Spur von |1><0|, was
die zwei Terme in der Antwort erklärt. Die Spur von |0><0|,
und deshalb ergeben diese beiden Terme null und tragen nichts zur Antwort bei. Wir können das nun ein wenig vereinfachen,
und was wir erhalten, ist der Nullzustand für das erste qubit, also A, und der vollständig gemischte Zustand für das
zweite qubit, also B. Beachte insbesondere, dass wir keinen Plusszustand für B erhalten haben, was nicht unbedingt
eine schlechte Vermutung wäre, wenn wir nichts über Dichtematrizen wüssten und nur auf die Quantenzustandsvektor-Darstellung des Zustands schauen würden. Aber das ist
nicht, wie dieser Kanal funktioniert, und es gibt keinen Kanal, der auf diese Weise funktionieren könnte. Der Kanal Lambda heißt zwar qubit-Reset-Kanal, aber
wie er funktioniert, ähnelt eher dem Wegwerfen des Eingangs-qubits und dem Ersetzen durch ein frisches qubit im Nullzustand. Aber das ist tatsächlich der
einzige qubit-Kanal, der immer den Nullzustand ausgibt. Hier ist ein weiteres Beispiel eines qubit-Kanals, bekannt als der
vollständig dephasierende Kanal. Dieser wird durch Delta bezeichnet, und wie er funktioniert ist, dass er die diagonalen
Einträge jeder 2x2-Matrix unverändert lässt und die außerdiagonalen Einträge auf null setzt. Delta ist der griechische Buchstabe, der dem D im
lateinischen Alphabet entspricht, und das ist eine Abkürzung für diagonal. So kann man sich merken, was dieser Kanal macht. Wir können
diesen Kanal alternativ mit Dirac-Notation ausdrücken, wie auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt. Und nur zur Klarheit: Die Ausgabe
ist immer eine 2x2-Matrix. Die beiden Null-Ausgaben beziehen sich insbesondere auf die Nullmatrix der Größe 2x2. Das machen wir häufig,
und wir haben das in dieser Serie schon gesehen: Das Symbol Null wird im Allgemeinen – vielleicht mehrdeutig – verwendet, um das Nullelement
von was auch immer wir gerade betrachten zu bezeichnen, ob es Skalare, Vektoren, Matrizen oder was auch immer sind. Machen wir dasselbe wie zuvor für den
qubit-Reset-Kanal und schauen, was passiert, wenn wir diesen Kanal auf die Hälfte eines ebits anwenden. Der Aufbau ist derselbe, also werde ich darauf nicht
erneut eingehen. Das Ergebnis ist der Zustand, der auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird, was im Wesentlichen ein gemeinsames zufälliges Bit ist. Was
dieser Kanal also getan hat, ist, ein ebit in ein perfekt korreliertes Paar klassischer zufälliger Bits umzuwandeln.
Und das stimmt mit einer allgemeineren Interpretation dieses Kanals überein: Indem wir die außerdiagonalen Einträge einer Dichtematrix auf null setzen, werfen wir effektiv
die Quanten-Anteile einer Dichtematrix weg und hinterlassen eine diagonale Dichtematrix, die einen
klassischen probabilistischen Zustand darstellt. Eine andere Art, darüber nachzudenken, ist, dass dieser Kanal einen perfekten rauschfreien klassischen Kanal darstellt, der ein Bit überträgt.
Wenn wir also einen Nullzustand, einen Einszustand oder eine Konvexkombination dieser beiden Zustände in den Kanal eingeben, kommt dieser Zustand unverändert heraus. Aber wenn du versuchst,
einen Quantenzustand einzugeben, wie zum Beispiel einen Plusszustand, ist es so, als ob der Kanal diesen Zustand mit einer Standardbasismessung misst und dann
das klassische Ergebnis überträgt. Ein letztes Beispiel eines qubit-Kanals ist der vollständig depolarisierende Kanal. Was
dieser Kanal macht, ist, immer den vollständig gemischten Zustand auszugeben. Er ist also dem qubit-Reset-Kanal in gewissem Sinne ähnlich,
außer dass wir einen weniger nützlichen vollständig gemischten Zustand erhalten, anstatt eines initialisierten qubits. Eine natürliche Art,
über diesen Kanal nachzudenken, ist, dass er eine extreme Form von Rauschen darstellt, und was qubit-Kanäle betrifft,
kann es nicht verrauschter werden. Ich habe keine gute Eselsbrücke, um sich zu merken, was dieser Kanal macht, außer zu sagen, dass Omega der letzte
Buchstabe des griechischen Alphabets ist und manchmal mit dem Ende aller Dinge assoziiert wird – und vielleicht ist das das, was
mit allen qubits irgendwann passiert. Was Rauschen betrifft, ist es ziemlich extrem. Aber eine Sache, die wir tun können, ist, eine Konvex-
kombination dieses Kanals und des Identitätskanals zu betrachten, mit vielleicht einer kleinen Wahrscheinlichkeit Epsilon für die vollständige
Depolarisierung – das ist eine weniger extreme Form von Rauschen, bei der ein gegebener qubit-Zustand meistens unverändert bleibt, es aber eine
kleine Wahrscheinlichkeit gibt, dass er vollständig gemischt wird. Geometrisch können wir uns das als eine leichte Kontraktion der Bloch-Sphäre zur Mitte hin vorstellen.
Übrigens können wir etwas Ähnliches mit dem vollständig dephasierenden Kanal machen, um zum Beispiel den Prozess der Dekohärenz zu modellieren, bei dem Dinge
durch irgendeinen Prozess etwas klassischer werden. Das sind also drei grundlegende Beispiele für qubit-Kanäle, und wir werden
im weiteren Verlauf der Lektion immer wieder auf sie als Beispielquellen zurückgreifen. Als nächstes besprechen wir mathematische
Darstellungen von Kanälen, beginnend mit einer grundlegenden Frage: Lineare Abbildungen von Vektoren auf Vektoren können immer
durch Matrizen dargestellt werden, und zwar auf die bekannte Weise, dass die Wirkung der linearen Abbildung durch Matrix-
Vektor-Multiplikation beschrieben wird. Aber Kanäle sind lineare Abbildungen von Matrizen auf Matrizen, nicht von Vektoren auf Vektoren. Wie also können wir
Kanäle im Allgemeinen mathematisch ausdrücken? Manchmal haben wir bei speziellen Kanälen eine einfache Formel,
die sie beschreibt – das war bei den qubit-Kanal-Beispielen, die wir bereits besprochen haben, der Fall. Aber das ist
im Allgemeinen nicht praktikabel, weil es nicht immer eine so schöne Formel geben wird. Als Vergleichspunkt: In der vereinfachten
Formulierung der Quanteninformation verwenden wir unitäre Matrizen, um Operationen auf Quantenzustandsvektoren darzustellen.
Jede unitäre Matrix stellt eine gültige Operation dar, und jede gültige Operation kann als unitäre Matrix ausgedrückt werden. Im
Wesentlichen fragt diese Frage also, wie wir das für Kanäle tun – und die Antwort ist, dass es tatsächlich mehrere Möglichkeiten gibt, Kanäle
mathematisch darzustellen. Insbesondere werden wir drei verschiedene Arten der Kanaldarstellung besprechen, die
nach drei Personen benannt sind, deren Arbeit eine wichtige Rolle bei ihrer Entwicklung spielte: Stinespring, Kraus und Choi.
Zunächst sehen wir, wie diese verschiedenen Darstellungen funktionieren, und dann im letzten Teil der Lektion, wie die drei Darstellungen zusammenhängen und wie wir
zwischen ihnen konvertieren können. Wir werden auch sehen, dass diese Darstellungen die Anforderungen, die wir an Kanäle stellen, genau erfassen:
nämlich dass sie lineare Abbildungen sind und dass sie Dichtematrizen immer in Dichtematrizen umwandeln, auch wenn
sie nur auf einen Teil eines zusammengesetzten Systems angewendet werden. Als erstes kommen die Stinespring-Darstellungen. Willam Forest Stine-
spring war ein Mathematiker, der nicht an Quanteninformation gearbeitet hat, und Stinespring-Darstellungen, wie ich sie beschreiben werde,
sind in gewissem Sinne nur eine Ableitung seiner Arbeit zur Operatortheorie in den 1950er Jahren. Aber diese Arbeit war ganz sicher
ein wichtiger Teil der Entwicklung der Mathematik, auf der Quantenkanäle basieren. Die Idee hinter dieser Art der Kanaldarstellung ist, dass jeder
Kanal auf eine bestimmte Weise implementiert werden kann, die ich nun beschreiben werde. Zuerst bilden wir ein zusammengesetztes System, bestehend aus dem
Eingang des zu implementierenden Kanals zusammen mit einem initialisierten Hilfssystem. Dann wird eine
unitäre Operation auf das zusammengesetzte System angewendet, und schließlich wird der Teil des resultierenden zusammengesetzten Systems,
der dem Ausgang des Kanals entspricht, unverändert gelassen bzw. ausgegeben, und der Rest wird verworfen oder auspartialisiert. Es ist hilfreich,
das in Form eines Diagramms darzustellen, und am einfachsten beginnt man mit dem Spezialfall, bei dem Eingangs- und
Ausgangssystem identisch sind. Dieses Diagramm ist übrigens genau wie ein Quanten-circuit-Diagramm, nur dass die Leitungen
beliebige Systeme darstellen und nicht notwendigerweise einzelne qubits. Wir beginnen also damit, dass das Eingangssystem X sich in einem
Zustand rho befindet. Wir führen ein initialisiertes Hilfssystem W ein, und in diesem Diagramm nehme ich an, dass Null ein klassischer
Zustand von W ist und wir ket-0 als den initialisierten Zustand des Systems nehmen. Wir könnten aber auch jeden reinen Zustand
von W als initialisierten Zustand festlegen. Wir führen dann eine unitäre Operation auf das Paar W, X aus und
partialisieren das Hilfssystem aus und geben X aus. Im Diagramm verwende ich übrigens das Erdungssymbol aus der
Elektrotechnik, um anzuzeigen, dass W verworfen wird. Das ist nicht unbedingt konventionell, und du wirst
dieses Symbol in Qiskit nicht finden – dort ignoriert man einfach die qubits, an denen man nicht interessiert ist. Der Punkt ist, dass ich einfach ein Symbol haben möchte, das deutlich macht,
dass wir das System für die Zwecke dieser Diskussion verwerfen. Im Allgemeinen müssen Eingangs- und Ausgangssystem nicht unbedingt identisch sein,
sodass wir beispielsweise ein Ausgangssystem Y zusammen mit einem Müllsystem G haben können, das auspartialisiert wird. Damit U unitär ist, muss es eine quadratische Matrix sein,
weshalb hier die Annahme gilt, dass das Paar G, Y zusammen genauso viele klassische Zustände hat wie das Paar W, X. Zum Beispiel bestehen diese Systeme vielleicht
aus qubits, und das Eingangssystem X besteht aus 5 qubits und W besteht aus, sagen wir, 10 qubits. Also ist U eine unitäre
Operation auf 15 qubits. Es könnte dann sein, dass Y aus nur vier qubits besteht, was bedeutet, dass G aus 11 qubits besteht.
Oder vielleicht sind das gar keine qubits – alles, was wichtig ist, ist, dass W, X zusammen und G, Y zusammen die gleiche Anzahl
klassischer Zustände haben, sodass U unitär sein kann. Eine Beschreibung eines Kanals wie diese wird als Stinespring-Darstellung des Kanals bezeichnet. Es ist nun
ziemlich unkompliziert zu argumentieren, dass jede Abbildung phi, die auf diese Weise beschrieben werden kann, tatsächlich ein gültiger Kanal ist. Wenn
wir mit der Dichtematrix beginnen und dann ein zusätzliches Hilfssystem anhängen, erhalten wir sicherlich wieder
eine Dichtematrix. Wir haben bereits beobachtet, dass die Anwendung einer unitären Operation einen gültigen Kanal ergibt, und
wenn wir eine Dichtematrix eines zusammengesetzten Systems haben und eines der Systeme auspartialisieren, erhalten wir wieder eine Dichtematrix. Wenn wir also
diese Schritte zusammensetzen, ist garantiert, dass Dichtematrizen immer in Dichtematrizen umgewandelt werden, und es ist auch linear.
Was an dieser Stelle überhaupt nicht klar ist, ist, dass jeder Kanal tatsächlich auf diese Weise für eine gewisse Wahl
des Hilfssystems und des Müllsystems sowie natürlich der unitären Operation U implementiert werden kann. Das ist aber wahr, und wir werden
bis zum Ende der Lektion sehen, warum. Hier ist ein Beispiel einer Stinespring-Darstellung für den vollständig dephasierenden
qubit-Kanal. Zur Klarstellung: Die Leitungen sind jetzt qubits, und das ist ein gewöhnliches kontrolliertes
NOT-gate. Es ist sehr einfach: Der Eingangs-qubit ist oben, und wir führen einen Hilfs-qubit ein, der auf den Null-
Zustand initialisiert wird. Dann führen wir eine kontrollierte NOT-Operation durch, bei der der Eingangs-qubit das Steuerelement und der Hilfs-qubit das
Ziel ist, und anschließend wird der Hilfs-qubit auspartialisiert. Intuitiv ergibt es Sinn,
dass das den vollständig dephasierenden Kanal implementieren sollte, weil das kontrollierte NOT-gate gewissermaßen wie eine Standardbasismessung am oberen
qubit wirkt, indem es dessen klassischen Zustand auf den unteren qubit kopiert und das Ergebnis dann
weggeworfen wird. Wir können aber auch eine Berechnung durchführen, und das ist natürlich eine gute Idee, weil wir
unserer Intuition nicht zu sehr vertrauen sollten. Wir können damit beginnen, die Dichtematrixdarstellung der
zwei qubits aufzuschreiben, nachdem der Hilfs-qubit eingeführt wurde, und dabei beachten, dass wir die qubit-Reihenfolge-Konvention
verwenden, wie üblich, wobei der untere qubit der linke ist und der obere qubit rechts steht. Wir können diese Dichtematrix
ausdrücken
explizit als eine tatsächliche 4x4-Matrix, wie auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt, und dann berechnen wir die Wirkung
die das Controlled-NOT-gate auf diese Dichtematrix hat, also konjugieren wir mit der unitären Matrix, die diesem
gate zugeordnet ist, dabei halten wir erneut die qubit-Anordnungskonvention im Blick, also ist dies die korrekte unitäre
Matrix und das Ergebnis ist hier gezeigt – im Wesentlichen hat das Controlled-NOT-gate
die Einträge unserer ursprünglichen Matrix ein wenig permutiert, sodass die möglicherweise von null verschiedenen Einträge nun in den
vier Ecken liegen. Es bleibt, die partielle Spur zu berechnen, was wir direkt aus der Matrix tun könnten, aber eine
Alternative ist, in die Dirac-Notation umzuwandeln, wie auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt, und dann wird es ziemlich einfach auszuwerten,
was passiert, wenn wir das qubit auf der linken Seite in jedem Term herausspuren, und das Ergebnis ist, dass nur die
Terme, die den Diagonaleinträgen der Dichtematrix entsprechen, überleben, und so haben wir das qubit wie
erwartet dephasiert. Überprüfe das wie immer selbst in deinem eigenen Tempo, wenn du das tun möchtest – es ist ein gutes
Beispiel, um etwas Übung im Umgang mit Dichtematrizen und mit partiellen
Spuren zu bekommen. Das ist nicht die einzige Möglichkeit, den vollständig dephasierenden Kanal zu implementieren. Hier ist eine alternative Stinespring-Darstellung für diesen
Kanal. Ich werde die Berechnung in diesem Video nicht im Detail durchgehen, aber ich zeige sie kurz, falls du das Video pausieren und einen genaueren
Blick darauf werfen möchtest. Die Funktionsweise ähnelt der ersten, aber die Details sind
anders. Diesmal beginnen wir mit einem Hadamard-gate auf dem Arbeitsraum-qubit, das es in einen Plus-Zustand versetzt, und wenn
wir das Tensorprodukt ausmultiplizieren, erhalten wir die Matrix, die auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird. Um das Controlled-Z-gate anzuwenden,
konjugieren wir mit der zugehörigen unitären Matrix, und das Ergebnis davon ist, einige Minuszeichen in die
Matrix einzufügen – insbesondere werden die letzte Zeile und die letzte Spalte beide mit -1 multipliziert.
Und diesmal wäre es ziemlich unübersichtlich, in die Dirac-Notation umzuwandeln, also berechnen wir die partielle Spur
direkt. Wenn wir das erste von zwei qubits herausspuren, erhalten wir die Summe der beiden diagonalen 2x2-Blöcke,
und das Endergebnis ist erneut, dass wir das qubit dephasiert haben. Das ging schnell, und wenn du
diese Art von Berechnungen nicht gewohnt bist, dann nimm dir die Zeit und mach es langsam – Geschwindigkeit ist nicht wichtig
hier. Um dieses Beispiel abzuschließen, lass mich erwähnen, dass hinter dieser Implementierung eine ziemlich einfache Idee steckt, die
durch den letzten Schritt der Berechnung, die wir gerade überflogen haben, recht schön ausgedrückt wird. Eine prägnantere Art, dies zu sagen,
ist: Wenn wir eine gegebene qubit-Dichtematrix mit der mit der Pauli-Z-Matrix konjugierten Dichtematrix mitteln, dann
ist das dasselbe wie dephasieren. Der vollständig dephasierende Kanal ist also ein gemischt-unitärer
Kanal, bei dem wir entweder nichts tun – also die Identitätsoperation ausführen – oder ein Z-gate ausführen, jeweils
mit Wahrscheinlichkeit 1/2. Gut zu wissen. Also haben wir zusammenfassend zwei verschiedene
Stinespring-Darstellungen des vollständig dephasierenden Kanals, und das sagt uns etwas Wichtiges: Stinespring-Darstellungen sind
nicht eindeutig, und tatsächlich gibt es für jeden gegebenen Kanal unendlich viele davon. Als Nächstes besprechen wir Kraus-
Darstellungen von Kanälen, die uns eine bequeme, formelhafte Möglichkeit bieten, Kanäle durch Matrix-
multiplikation und Addition auszudrücken. Kraus-Darstellungen sind nach Karl Kraus benannt, einem Physiker, der unter
anderem viele der grundlegenden mathematischen Details von Kanälen und die allgemeine Formulierung von Quanteninformation im weiteren Sinne ausgearbeitet hat. Im Allgemeinen ist eine
Kraus-Darstellung ein Ausdruck eines Kanals in der Form, die hier auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird. Insbesondere haben wir eine
Sammlung von Matrizen, die hier A₀ bis A_ für eine positive ganze Zahl n benannt sind, und sie bestimmen die
Wirkung des Kanals auf jede gegebene Eingabe-Dichtematrix gemäß der Formel. Kurz gesagt konjugieren wir die Dichtematrix mit jeder dieser Matrizen,
die in diesem Kontext oft als Kraus-Matrizen bezeichnet werden, und addieren dann das Ergebnis, was uns die Ausgabe liefert. Alle diese Matrizen müssen
die gleichen Dimensionen haben, und insbesondere müssen ihre Spalten den klassischen Zuständen des Eingabesystems entsprechen und
die Zeilen müssen den klassischen Zuständen des Ausgabesystems entsprechen. Wenn das der Fall ist, erhalten wir beim Produkt Aₖ * ρ * Aₖ† für jede
Wahl von k eine quadratische Matrix, deren Zeilen und Spalten den klassischen Zuständen des Ausgabesystems entsprechen.
Es ist also sinnvoll, dass der Ausdruck eine Dichtematrix des Ausgabesystems liefert. Nun ist es nicht der Fall,
dass wir bei einer beliebigen Wahl dieser Kraus-Matrizen einen gültigen Kanal erhalten. Es gibt jedoch eine ziemlich einfache
Bedingung an die Matrizen, die garantiert, dass wir einen gültigen Kanal erhalten, und diese Bedingung ist die hier angezeigte Formel.
Konkret: Wenn wir die Summe des Produkts Aₖ† * Aₖ über alle Werte von k bilden,
dann müssen wir die Identitätsmatrix erhalten, und zwar die Identitätsmatrix, deren Zeilen und Spalten den
klassischen Zuständen des Eingabesystems entsprechen. Diese Bedingung muss also erfüllt sein, damit die durch die
erste Gleichung definierte Abbildung ein gültiger Kanal ist. Und es stellt sich heraus, dass jeder Kanal tatsächlich eine Darstellung besitzt, die diese
Form hat, solange wir n groß genug wählen. Hier sind einige Beispiele für Kraus-
Darstellungen, beginnend mit dem qubit-Reset-Kanal. Wir können eine Kraus-Darstellung für diesen Kanal erhalten, indem wir
zwei Kraus-Matrizen verwenden: |0⟩⟨0| und |0⟩⟨1|, also ist n gleich zwei in diesem Beispiel.
Wir können diese Wahlen in die allgemeine Formel einsetzen und haben nur zwei Terme, sodass die Summe leicht aufzuschreiben ist.
Und wenn wir vereinfachen und erkennen, dass der Ausdruck in der Klammer die Spur von ρ ist, sehen wir, dass wir
den qubit-Reset-Kanal erhalten. Wir können auch überprüfen, dass die erforderliche Bedingung an diese Matrizen erfüllt ist, was eine einfache Sache ist: man setzt die Kraus-
Matrizen in die Gleichung ein und wertet aus, und wir erhalten die Identitätsmatrix, wie es gefordert ist. Als weiteres Beispiel werfen wir erneut einen Blick auf den
vollständig dephasierenden Kanal. Die Matrizen |0⟩⟨0| und |1⟩⟨1| zu nehmen funktioniert, und das kann durch
Ausmultiplizieren der Summe überprüft werden, wobei man ziemlich direkt sieht, dass man erhält, was man braucht. Und erneut ist die erforderliche Bedingung erfüllt. Eine
Alternative ist, A₀ als die Identitätsmatrix geteilt durch √2 zu wählen und A₁ als
Sigma Z geteilt durch √2, und wenn wir auswerten, sehen wir, dass wir erneut den vollständig dephasierenden Kanal erhalten, basierend auf der Beobachtung,
die wir zu diesem Kanal etwas früher in der Lektion gemacht haben. Und erneut ist die erforderliche Bedingung ziemlich unkompliziert zu
überprüfen. Als Übung, die du durcharbeiten kannst, falls du das hilfreich findest: Betrachte den vollständig depolarisierenden
Kanal, der für jede Dichtematrix-Eingabe den vollständig gemischten Zustand ausgibt. Für diesen werden vier Kraus-Matrizen
benötigt – es ist nicht möglich, eine Kraus-Darstellung mit n gleich drei oder weniger zu finden. Hier ist eine Wahl, die funktioniert, und
hier ist eine weitere Übungsaufgabe: Überprüfe, ob diese Entscheidungen funktionieren, und überprüfe außerdem, ob die geforderte Bedingung
erfüllt ist. Es lohnt sich darauf hinzuweisen, dass die zweite Alternative im Grunde besagt, dass es möglich ist, einen qubit vollständig zu depolarisieren, oder mit anderen Worten,
ihn vollständig zu randomisieren, indem man zufällig eine der vier Pauli-Matrizen einschließlich der Identität wählt und die
entsprechende unitäre Operation auf den qubit anwendet. Der vollständig depolarisierende Kanal ist also ein weiteres Beispiel für einen gemischten
unitären Kanal. Die letzte der drei Kanaldarstellungen, die wir behandeln werden, ist die Choi-Darstellung. Manduan Choi
ist ein Mathematiker, der sich mit Matrizentheorie und anderen Themen beschäftigt, und die Choi-Darstellung ist ihm zu Ehren benannt,
basierend auf einem wirklich eleganten Artikel, den er 1975 veröffentlichte, der in gewissem Sinne all diese Dinge zusammenführt. Die Choi-
Darstellung eines Kanals f ist eine einzelne Matrix, die konventionell mit jfi bezeichnet wird. Genauer gesagt, wenn das
Eingabesystem n klassische Zustände hat und das Ausgabesystem M klassische Zustände, dann ist die Choi-Darstellung von f
eine n * m mal n * m quadratische Matrix. Bevor ich dir genau erkläre, wie die Matrix definiert ist, möchte ich ein paar
ihrer wichtigsten Eigenschaften erwähnen, die die Darstellung in einer Weise motivieren, wie es die eigentliche Definition selbst vielleicht nicht tut – zumindest
auf den ersten Blick. Erstens: Im Gegensatz sowohl zu Stinespring-Darstellungen als auch zu Kraus-Darstellungen ist die Choi-Darstellung
eine sogenannte treue Darstellung, was bedeutet, dass jeder Kanal genau eine davon hat, und das ist ziemlich wichtig,
denn es besagt, dass zwei Kanäle genau dann gleich sind, wenn ihre Choi-Darstellungen gleich sind. Wenn du also
zwei verschiedene Beschreibungen von Kanälen hast, wie etwa zwei verschiedene Stinespring-Darstellungen oder zwei verschiedene Kraus-Darstellungen, oder vielleicht eine von
jeder, und wissen möchtest, ob es sich tatsächlich um denselben Kanal handelt, kannst du einfach die Choi-Darstellung berechnen und
prüfen, ob sie gleich sind. Die zweite Eigenschaft besteht darin, dass es einfache Bedingungen gibt, die für die Choi-Darstellung genau dann gelten, wenn
wir einen gültigen Kanal haben. Diese Eigenschaft ist nicht ganz so besonders – dasselbe können wir über die anderen beiden Darstellungen sagen – aber es ist eine gute Eigenschaft,
die man dennoch haben sollte, und wir werden sie weiter unten ausführlicher besprechen. Noch etwas zur Choi-Darstellung: Obwohl wir einen
Kanal durch eine Matrix darstellen, repräsentiert diese Matrix den Kanal nicht direkt als lineare Abbildung. Tatsächlich ist es
natürlicher, die Choi-Darstellung mit der Dichtematrix zu assoziieren, die einen bestimmten Zustand repräsentiert,
als die Choi-Darstellung als Beschreibung einer linearen Abbildung zu betrachten. Es ist jedoch möglich, die Wirkung des Kanals aus
seiner Choi-Darstellung mithilfe einer ziemlich einfachen Formel zu rekonstruieren, aber es ist nicht so einfach wie eine gewöhnliche Matrix-
multiplikation. Genug der Vorrede – kommen wir zur eigentlichen Definition. Angenommen, wir haben einen Kanal fi von einem System X zu einem System Y,
und wir nehmen an, dass die klassische Zustandsmenge des Eingabesystems X gleich Sigma ist. Wir werden die klassische Zustandsmenge des Ausgabesystems nicht benötigen, also
brauchen wir diese für die Definition nicht zu benennen. Die Choi-Darstellung von fi wird dann durch den
hier auf dem Bildschirm gezeigten Ausdruck definiert. Wir haben eine Summe über alle klassischen Zustände A und B des Eingabesystems, und wir
summieren k a bra B tensoriert mit dem auf k a bra B angewendeten Kanal fi. Diese
Darstellung ist also durch eine Formel definiert, und es gibt ein paar verschiedene Möglichkeiten, über diese Formel nachzudenken. Bevor ich sie jedoch bespreche,
möchte ich erwähnen, dass die Choi-Darstellung manchmal leicht anders definiert wird, wobei die Reihenfolge der beiden Tensorfaktoren vertauscht ist, was bedeutet,
dass fi von k a bra als erster Tensorfaktor statt als zweiter erscheint. Die beiden verschiedenen Varianten sind aber
bis auf diese einfache Symmetrie äquivalent. Was das jedoch bedeutet, ist, dass es bei der Verwendung dieser Darstellung eine gute
Idee ist, klarzustellen, welche Reihenfolge du verwendest. Diese Reihenfolge ist die Vorgehensweise in qiskit, und sie eignet sich auch besser für
die visuelle Beschreibung der Darstellung in Form von Blockmatrizen. Deshalb werden wir damit weitermachen. Um die Blockmatrix-
beschreibung genauer zu beschreiben: Wenn wir annehmen, dass die klassische Zustandsmenge Sigma aus den ganzen Zahlen von null bis n minus eins
für eine positive ganze Zahl n besteht, dann können wir jfi alternativ als Blockmatrix schreiben, wie hier auf dem
Bildschirm gezeigt. Mit anderen Worten: Die Choi-Darstellung von fi ist die Matrix, die wir erhalten, indem wir fi auf jede der
Eingabematrizen anwenden, die genau einen Eintrag gleich eins haben und bei denen alle anderen Einträge null sind, und sie dann
auf eine ziemlich natürliche Weise zu einer Matrix anordnen. Es ist vielleicht nicht a priori klar, warum wir eine solche Matrix bilden möchten, aber es
erweist sich als sehr nützlich. Eine Sache, die man beachten sollte, ist, dass die Menge der Matrizen k a bra b, wenn
a und b beide alle ganzen Zahlen von 0 bis n minus eins durchlaufen, eine Basis für den Raum aller n mal n Matrizen bildet. Wenn du also
diese Matrix hast, kannst du durch Linearität sicher bestimmen, was fi mit einer beliebigen n mal n Matrix macht,
und zwar indem du geeignete Linearkombinationen der Blöcke bildest. Die Matrix jfi bestimmt fi also tatsächlich eindeutig
als lineare Abbildung. Eine andere Möglichkeit, über die Choi-Darstellung eines Kanals nachzudenken, besteht darin, dass sie
einen Zustand als Dichtematrix darstellt, wenn sie normiert ist – genauer gesagt durch Division durch die Anzahl der
klassischen Zustände des Eingabesystems, die ich weiterhin mit dem Kleinbuchstaben n bezeichne. Das ergibt immer eine
Dichtematrix, die oft als Choi-Zustand des Kanals bezeichnet wird. Hier ist, wie das im Detail funktioniert:
Stelle dir zunächst vor, dass wir zwei identische Kopien des Eingabesystems haben, und betrachte den Quantenzustandsvektor s,
der auf dem Bildschirm angezeigt wird und einen sogenannten maximal verschränkten Zustand dieses Paares identischer Systeme darstellt.
Wenn Sigma zum Beispiel das binäre Alphabet ist, dann ist dies ein phi+-Zustand, aber wir können uns einen analog definierten Zustand für
jede Wahl von Sigma vorstellen, und was wir erhalten, ist ein Zustand, der stark verschränkt ist – und zwar so stark, wie es
bei dieser Wahl von Systemen möglich ist. Um die Dichtematrixdarstellung des Zustands zu erhalten, multiplizieren wir den Zustandsvektor mit seiner konjugierten Transponierten, wie üblich,
und so sieht das aus. Und schließlich: Wenn wir über die Choi-Darstellung des Kanals dividiert durch n nachdenken, sehen wir, dass es der Zustand ist,
den wir erhalten würden, wenn wir den Kanal fi auf das zweite System anwenden würden. In Form einer Abbildung sieht das
so aus: Wir haben zwei Kopien des Systems X in diesem maximal verschränkten Zustand s. Der Kanal f wird
auf das zweite System angewendet, das im Diagramm oben dargestellt ist, und der resultierende Zustand ist der Choi-Zustand von fi. Normalerweise würden wir
zwei verschiedenen Systemen nicht denselben Namen geben – es ist generell nicht hilfreich, zwei verschiedenen Dingen denselben Namen zu geben – aber es macht Sinn,
dies in diesem Fall zu tun, nur um diese Verbindung mit Choi-Darstellungen herzustellen. Es gibt ein paar Schlussfolgerungen, die wir unmittelbar aus dieser Betrachtungsweise
von Choi-Darstellungen ziehen können. Eine ist, dass, da der Choi-Zustand eine Dichtematrix ist – vorausgesetzt, f ist ein
gültiger Kanal –, wir daraus schließen, dass die Choi-Darstellung von fi positiv semidefinit sein muss. Denk daran, dass es eine
Anforderung ist, die wir an Kanäle stellen, dass sie Dichtematrizen immer in Dichtematrizen überführen, und das
ist nur ein spezieller Fall davon. Die zweite Schlussfolgerung ist, dass wenn wir den Choi-Zustand für einen beliebigen Kanal fi nehmen und
dann die Ausgabe von System Y verwerfen, dann muss uns der vollständig gemischte Zustand auf dem Eingabesystem X verbleiben – das liegt
daran, dass das Anwenden eines Kanals auf ein System und das anschließende Wegwerfen des resultierenden Systems in den Müll äquivalent ist dazu, das ursprüngliche System einfach in den
Müll zu werfen. Und wenn wir das mit unserem maximal verschränkten Zustand täten, wäre die Dichtematrix, die uns bliebe,
die Identitätsmatrix dividiert durch n – oder mit anderen Worten der vollständig gemischte Zustand für System X. Die Idee in
mathematischen Begriffen ist, dass die Komposition eines beliebigen Kanals mit der Spur auf dem Ausgabesystem gleich der Spur auf dem
Eingabesystem sein muss – und das, weil Kanäle die Spur erhalten müssen, da sie lineare Abbildungen sind, die
Dichtematrizen stets in Dichtematrizen transformieren. Sobald wir diese Gleichung haben, können wir den Nenner n
auf beiden Seiten wegkürzen, um eine etwas sauberere Bedingung zu erhalten. In Worten: das Ausführen der partiellen Spur über das Ausgabesystem
der Choi-Darstellung eines Kanals muss uns die Identitätsmatrix auf dem Eingabesystem liefern. Zusammenfassend:
Choi-Darstellungen von Kanälen sind stets positiv semidefinit, und wenn wir das Ausgabesystem herausspuren, bleibt uns zwangsläufig
die Identitätsmatrix auf dem Eingabesystem. Wie sich herausstellt, sind das nicht nur notwendige Bedingungen, sondern
auch hinreichende – das bedeutet, wenn fi eine beliebige lineare Abbildung ist und diese zwei Bedingungen zufällig beide erfüllt sind,
dann muss fi tatsächlich ein gültiger Kanal sein. Und wir werden bis zum Ende der Lektion sehen, warum das der Fall ist.
Schauen wir uns ein paar Beispiele an, beginnend mit dem vollständig dephasierenden Kanal. Um die Choi-Darstellung zu berechnen, geht es darum,
die Formel auszuwerten. Der vollständig dephasierende Kanal lässt ket a bra B unverändert, wenn a gleich B ist, andernfalls ist die Ausgabe
null. Die Terme der Summe, die überleben, sind also die, bei denen a gleich B ist, und das Ergebnis wird auf dem
Bildschirm in Dirac-Notation ausgedrückt. Wir können es auch als Blockmatrix betrachten: Delta lässt Diagonaleinträge unverändert und nullt die Nicht-
diagonaleinträge aus. So bleibt uns eine Matrix mit Einsen in den oberen linken und unteren rechten Ecken, wobei alle
übrigen Einträge null sind – das stimmt mit dem ersten Ausdruck überein. Als weiteres Beispiel betrachten wir den vollständig depolarisierenden Kanal. Auch hier
können wir die Formel aufschreiben, und genau wie im vorherigen Beispiel erhalten wir keinen Beitrag zur Summe,
wenn a nicht gleich B ist. Und dieses Mal erhalten wir, wenn a gleich B ist, den vollständig gemischten Zustand. Das vereinfacht sich zu
1/2 mal die 2x2-Identitätsmatrix tensoriert mit sich selbst, was 1/2 mal die 4x4-
Identitätsmatrix ergibt. Wir können das auch anhand von Blockmatrizen betrachten und erhalten natürlich dasselbe Ergebnis. Als
letztes Beispiel betrachten wir den Identitätskanal für ein einzelnes qubit – ein einfaches Beispiel. Hier ist die Formel, und
natürlich tut der Identitätskanal überhaupt nichts. Wir können das Ergebnis als das Zweifache der Dichtematrix des Zustands phi+ betrachten – und das
stimmt mit dem überein, was wir erwarten, wenn wir über den Choi-Zustand dieses Kanals nachdenken. Und hier ist er als Blockmatrix. Man beachte insbesondere, dass die Choi-
Darstellung des Identitätskanals nicht die Identitätsmatrix ist – es ist diese Matrix. Wir haben jetzt drei verschiedene
Möglichkeiten gesehen, Kanäle in mathematischen Begriffen darzustellen, nämlich Stinespring-Darstellungen, Kraus-Darstellungen und Choi-
Darstellungen. Außerdem haben wir die Definition eines Kanals: Ein Kanal ist eine lineare Abbildung, die
Dichtematrizen stets in Dichtematrizen transformiert, selbst wenn der Kanal nur auf einen Teil eines zusammengesetzten Systems angewendet wird. Eine sehr natürliche und wichtige
Frage ist an diesem Punkt: Woher wissen wir, dass all diese Dinge äquivalent sind? Zum Beispiel: Woher wissen wir, dass jede
Abbildung, die durch eine dieser Darstellungen beschrieben wird, tatsächlich ein gültiger Kanal ist? Und woher wissen wir, dass wir keine Kanäle auslassen? Der
Rest der Lektion beschreibt, wie all das mathematisch begründet werden kann. Wenn du bereit bist, die Äquivalenz dieser Dinge zu akzeptieren und es dich nicht interessiert, wie es begründet werden kann,
solltest du den Rest des Videos gerne überspringen. Ich persönlich finde das Argument aber ziemlich
elegant, und es ist ein gutes Beispiel für einen bestimmten Stil mathematischer Beweise, der in der Theorie der Quanteninformation immer wieder auftaucht. Ich werde nicht auf
alle Details eingehen – einige davon überlasse ich dir, oder du findest sie im schriftlichen Inhalt zu dieser Lektion, wo alles vollständig ausgearbeitet ist.
Aber ich hoffe, ein einigermaßen klares Bild davon zu vermitteln, wie das Ganze funktioniert. Was wir tun möchten, ist die
Äquivalenz einer Sammlung von Aussagen zu beweisen. Und das können wir erreichen, indem wir einen Zyklus von Implikationen aufstellen. Insbesondere beginnen wir
mit der Definition eines Kanals – also einer linearen Abbildung, die Dichtematrizen stets in Dichtematrizen transformiert.
Aus dieser Definition können wir schlussfolgern, dass die Choi-Darstellung dieses Kanals die zwei Bedingungen erfüllen muss, die wir
bereits besprochen haben. Und tatsächlich haben wir das schon getan – das wurde im Zusammenhang mit dem Choi-Zustand eines Kanals besprochen. Danach vergessen wir die
Definition und arbeiten mit der Choi-Darstellung. Angesichts unserer zwei Bedingungen für Choi-Darstellungen schlussfolgern wir, dass es eine Kraus-
Darstellung der Abbildung fi geben muss. Dann machen wir etwas Analoges: Wir vergessen Choi-Darstellungen und arbeiten
mit einer beliebigen Kraus-Darstellung. Daraus können wir schlussfolgern, dass es eine Stinespring-Darstellung für die Abbildung fi geben muss. Und diese
Argumente sind in gewissem Sinne mechanisch, was uns erlaubt, die Konvertierungen gemäß den Pfeilen für spezifische Kanäle tatsächlich durchzuführen, wenn wir das
möchten. Die letzte Implikation besteht darin, zu begründen, dass wenn wir eine Stinespring-Darstellung für eine Abbildung fi haben,
diese Abbildung tatsächlich ein gültiger Kanal sein muss. Und auch das haben wir bereits getan – dieses Mal im Zusammenhang mit Stinespring-
Darstellungen. Zusammen enthüllen diese vier Implikationen, dass diese vier Dinge alle äquivalent sind, weil man bei jedem von ihnen anfangen und
den Implikationen transitiv folgen kann, um zu jedem der anderen zu gelangen. Wir beginnen mit der ersten Implikation:
Wenn wir einen Kanal fi haben – also eine lineare Abbildung, die Dichtematrizen stets in Dichtematrizen transformiert –, dann hat er eine Choi-
Darstellung, die die zwei Bedingungen erfüllt, die wir zuvor identifiziert haben, nämlich dass sie positiv semidefinit ist
und dass wir die Identität auf dem Eingabesystem erhalten, wenn wir das Ausgabesystem herausspuren. Und wie ich eben erwähnt habe, haben wir
diese Implikation bereits im Zusammenhang mit Choi-Zuständen behandelt. Insbesondere wenn wir die Choi-Darstellung eines Kanals durch n dividieren – die Anzahl der
klassischen Zustände des Eingabesystems –, erhalten wir eine Dichtematrix. Und außerdem ist der reduzierte Zustand des
Eingabesystems X für diesen Zustand der vollständig gemischte Zustand – oder mit anderen Worten die Identitätsmatrix dividiert durch n. Das Wegkürzen des Nenners liefert uns unsere
zwei Bedingungen. Diese Implikation ist also ziemlich schnell und einfach, da wir sie bereits behandelt
haben. Schauen wir uns nun die zweite Implikation an. Dieses Mal beginnen wir mit der Choi-Darstellung einer Abbildung,
von der wir annehmen, dass sie die zwei Anforderungen erfüllt. Unser Ziel ist es, eine Kraus-Darstellung für diese Abbildung zu finden, die
die Anforderung erfüllt, über die wir zuvor gesprochen haben. Diese Implikation ist in gewissem Sinne ziemlich mechanisch. Wir brauchen ein
bisschen lineare Algebra, und es läuft hauptsächlich darauf hinaus, Matrizen und Vektoren auf eine ziemlich clevere
Art und Weise zu manipulieren. Es beginnt mit der Annahme, dass die Choi-Darstellung positiv semidefinit ist – das ist die erste der zwei Anforderungen, die wir als
gegeben annehmen. Der Begriff einer positiv semidefiniten Matrix ist grundlegend wichtig in der Quanteninformation – und nicht nur im Zusammenhang mit Dichte-
Matrizen ist hier absolut entscheidend – ohne sie würden wir das nicht zum Laufen bringen können. Insbesondere die Annahme,
dass jfi positiv semidefinit ist, erlaubt es uns, sie in der auf dem Bildschirm gezeigten Form darzustellen – für eine bestimmte Wahl von
Vektoren s0 bis S N minus eins und für eine bestimmte Wahl einer positiven ganzen Zahl n. Ich möchte ausdrücklich darauf hinweisen, dass dies
nicht unbedingt Einheitsvektoren sind. Eine Möglichkeit, an so einen Ausdruck heranzukommen, liefert uns der Spektralsatz für positive
semidefinite Matrizen, der in der vorherigen Lektion besprochen wurde. Hier sehen wir keine EW-Werte, die explizit auftauchen, wie wir es in einer Spektral-
zerlegung hatten. Aber denk daran, dass die EW-Werte positiv semidefiniter Matrizen immer nicht-negative reelle Zahlen sind. Behalte außerdem im Hinterkopf, dass wir
nicht verlangen, dass diese Vektoren S 0 bis S N minus eins Einheitsvektoren sind. Was wir also tun können, ist, die Quadratwurzeln der
EW-Werte zu nehmen und sie in die Einheits-Eigenvektoren zu multiplizieren, die wir aus einer Spektralzerlegung erhalten, um diese
Vektoren s0 bis S N minus1 zu bekommen. Für diesen Beweis ist es eigentlich nicht wichtig, dass diese Vektoren orthogonal sind. Das erhalten wir zwar
aus einer Spektralzerlegung, aber wir werden das hier nicht verwenden. Und wenn wir einen anderen Ausdruck für jfi wie diesen hätten, der nicht aus dem
Spektralsatz stammt, wäre das völlig in Ordnung. Wir zerlegen nun jeden dieser Vektoren, wie auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt, und
das ist genau wie wir es tun würden, wenn diese Vektoren Quanten-Zustandsvektoren eines Paares von Systemen XY wären und wir
eine Standardbasismessung am X-System durchführen würden. Um das klarzustellen: Wir messen hier nichts – wir schreiben diese Vektoren nur in dieser Form, was
immer möglich ist. Und jetzt kommt der Trick: Wir definieren Kraus-Matrizen a0 bis a n minus eins, indem wir das K
der A's vom Anfang dieser Vektoren s0 bis S N minus eins abziehen, sie umdrehen, sodass sie zu Bra-A's werden statt
zu Ket-A's, und sie auf der rechten Seite anhängen, wie in der Gleichung auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt. Eine Möglichkeit, das zu verstehen,
ist, dass wir diese Vektoren im Wesentlichen zu Matrizen falten. Wenn wir die Spalten von AK übereinanderstapeln würden, erhielten wir
wieder s. Diese Matrizen haben also genau dieselben Einträge wie die entsprechenden Vektoren, aber wir haben die
Einträge einfach anders angeordnet, sodass wir Matrizen erhalten. Wir können diese Matrizen aber auch rein symbolisch in Form der Dirac-Notation betrachten,
wie hier geschrieben. Und jetzt stellt sich eine naheliegende Frage: Warum sollte das funktionieren? Nun, lass uns nicht zu lange darüber nachdenken,
warum es funktioniert – lass uns einfach überprüfen, dass es das tut. Dazu definieren wir eine neue Abbildung, nämlich die Abbildung, die durch
diese Matrizen definiert wird, wobei wir sie als Kraus-Matrizen behandeln. Was wir jetzt tun können, ist die Choi-Darstellung dieser
neuen Abbildung zu berechnen. Wir werden sehen, dass sie gleich der Choi-Darstellung der Abbildung F ist, mit der wir begonnen haben. Und
da Choi-Darstellungen treu sind, bedeutet das, dass die beiden Abbildungen tatsächlich gleich sind. Ich werde die Algebra in diesem Video nicht durchgehen –
du kannst das selbst nachprüfen. Es ist ziemlich mechanisch und eine gute Übung, und alles, was du dafür brauchst, ist direkt
hier auf dem Bildschirm. Wir haben noch nichts über die zweiten Bedingungen in den beiden Kästen gesagt, aber sie
erweisen sich als äquivalent. Eine Möglichkeit, das zu zeigen, besteht darin, die unten auf dem Bildschirm angezeigte Gleichung zu überprüfen.
Der Buchstabe T hier bezieht sich übrigens auf die Matrixtransposition, die du alternativ als die
lineare Abbildung betrachten kannst, die Ket a Bra b in Ket b Bra a umwandelt. Das ist einfach etwas, das benötigt wird, damit die Formel funktioniert. Also:
Zusammenfassend lässt sich sagen, dass für diese Implikation definitiv etwas Algebra nötig ist, aber wie gesagt ist alles ziemlich mechanisch –
im Grunde Indexgymnastik, wie manche Leute diese Art von Dingen nennen. Aber wenn du es durcharbeitest und deinem Gehirn die Möglichkeit gibst, es zu verdauen, wirst du vielleicht
feststellen, dass du am Ende ein besseres Verständnis davon hast, wie Choi-Darstellungen und Kraus-Darstellungen zusammenhängen. Die dritte Implikation ermöglicht es uns,
von einer Kraus-Darstellung einer Abbildung fi, bei der die übliche Bedingung gilt, zu einer Stinespring-Darstellung überzugehen. Diese
ist vom Geist her der vorherigen Implikation ähnlich, in dem Sinne, dass sie mechanisch ist und rein algebraisch betrachtet und überprüft werden kann. Die
Idee ist eigentlich ziemlich einfach: Was wir tun können, ist, unsere Kraus-Matrizen zu nehmen und Teil einer größeren Matrix zu bilden, indem wir sie
übereinanderstapeln, wie auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt. Einmal ausgefüllt, wird uns das die unitäre Matrix U für eine
Stinespring-Darstellung liefern. Unitäre Matrizen müssen quadratische Matrizen sein, also müssen wir so viele restliche
Spalten auffüllen, wie wir brauchen. Aber es spielt eigentlich keine Rolle, was diese sind, solange wir eine unitäre
Matrix erhalten. Wenn wir die Frage, ob U unitär ist, vorübergehend beiseitelassen und uns nur auf die lineare Abbildung konzentrieren, die durch
die Stinespring-Darstellung definiert wird, die wir aus dieser Matrix U erhalten, dann stellen wir fest, dass die Abbildung gleich der
ursprünglichen Abbildung fi ist, die durch die Kraus-Darstellung definiert wurde, mit der wir begonnen haben. Das ist ein weiterer Teil des Beweises, den ich in diesem Video nicht durchgehen werde – du kannst
die Details im schriftlichen Inhalt zu dieser Lektion finden. Aber du möchtest vielleicht alternativ etwas Zeit aufwenden und es selbst durcharbeiten. Denk nur
daran, wie üblich für die Reihe, dass wir die Ket-Anordnungskonvention verwenden, um das Diagramm zu interpretieren. Also werden w und G
den Tensorfaktoren auf der linken Seite in den Gleichungen entsprechen. Und übrigens, wenn du es
durchgehst, wirst du feststellen, dass wir, weil wir k0o Bra null als Tensorfaktor auf der linken Seite in der Gleichung haben,
die wir überprüfen müssen, nur den Teil von U relevant ist, der durch die Kraus-Matrix gegeben ist. Solange wir also die
Spalten von U so auffüllen, dass es unitär wird, sind wir fertig. Das setzt natürlich voraus, dass die Spalten, die durch a0 bis a n minus
eins gebildet werden, wenn wir sie übereinanderstapeln, orthonormal sind. Und hier kommt die Bedingung ins Spiel, die wir an Kraus-Darstellungen stellen.
Und tatsächlich ist sie genau äquivalent dazu, dass die Spalten orthonormal sind. Die relevanten mathematischen Zusammenhänge, die nötig sind, um diese
Schlussfolgerung zu ziehen, sind unten auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt. Also mach ruhig eine Pause und überprüfe das, wenn du möchtest – oder
schau dir den schriftlichen Inhalt für weitere Details an. Kurz gesagt: Was hier bei dieser Implikation und bei der
vorherigen passiert, ist, dass wir dieselben mathematischen Operationen auf verschiedene, aber äquivalente Weisen beschreiben. Das
schlagende Herz von allem ist im Wesentlichen die Matrixmultiplikation. Die vierte und letzte Implikation zeigt, dass wenn wir eine
Stinespring-Darstellung für eine Abbildung haben, diese Abbildung tatsächlich ein gültiger Kanal sein muss. Und wie ich bereits erwähnt habe,
haben wir diese Implikation bereits behandelt, als wir Stinespring-Darstellungen besprochen haben. Zusammenfassend und in
etwas anderen Begriffen: Das Einführen eines initialisierten Arbeitsbereichssystems ist ein gültiger Kanal, weil das Tensorieren einer festen
Dichtematrix mit einer gegebenen Dichtematrix immer eine Dichtematrix ergibt und eine lineare Abbildung durch die Bilinearität
von Tensorprodukten ist. Unitäre Operationen sind immer gültige Kanäle, wie ich zuvor in der Lektion besprochen habe. Das Ausspuren eines Systems ist ein gültiger Kanal, weil die
partielle Spur eine lineare Abbildung ist, die Dichtematrizen immer in Dichtematrizen transformiert. Und schließlich sind Kompositionen von
Kanälen immer Kanäle, was ziemlich einfach ist, aber definitiv für sich genommen erwähnenswert ist. Und mit den
vier Implikationen, die wir gerade behandelt haben, haben wir die Äquivalenz unserer drei Kanaldarstellungen zusammen mit der
ursprünglichen Definition eines Kanals etabliert. Insbesondere begannen wir mit der Definition eines Kanals, sahen, wie diese Definition impliziert, dass seine Choi-
Darstellung notwendigerweise zwei grundlegende Bedingungen erfüllt. Dann sahen wir, wie diese Bedingungen es uns ermöglichen, eine Kraus-Darstellung zu finden, die wiederum
ermöglicht, eine Stinespring-Darstellung zu finden. Und schließlich sahen wir, dass die Existenz einer Stinespring-Darstellung zeigt, dass wir tatsächlich
einen gültigen Kanal haben. Natürlich gibt es technische Details, und es ist nicht unbedingt einfach, besonders
wenn du es zum ersten Mal siehst. Aber was hier interessant und bemerkenswert ist, ist, dass diese Implikationen so aufgebaut sind, dass sie es tatsächlich
so einfach wie möglich machen. Und in der Mathematik solltest du dich niemals schämen, den einfachen Weg zu nehmen. Zum
Beispiel ist es überhaupt nicht offensichtlich, dass jeder Kanal eine Stinespring-Darstellung oder eine Kraus-Darstellung hat.
Aber es ist relativ leicht zu schlussfolgern, dass die Choi-Darstellung jedes Kanals die zwei Bedingungen erfüllt, die wir damit verbunden haben. Und das
ermöglicht es uns, einem mehr oder weniger algebraischen Weg zu den anderen beiden Darstellungen zu folgen. In ähnlicher Weise ist die
letzte Implikation – von einer Stinespring-Darstellung zurück zur Definition – ebenfalls relativ unkompliziert. Und sie
ermöglicht es uns zu schlussfolgern, dass wir aus Choi-Darstellungen nur Kanäle und keine anderen Abbildungen erhalten, vorausgesetzt,
die erforderlichen Bedingungen sind erfüllt. Und wie ich zuvor angedeutet habe: Die Art und Weise, wie wir diese Implikationen argumentieren, ist ausreichend mechanisch, um es uns leicht zu machen,
zwischen den Darstellungen zu konvertieren. Und wenn du zu einigen der Beispiele zurückgehst, die wir früher in der Lektion behandelt haben, wirst du feststellen, dass es tatsächlich möglich ist,
zwischen den Darstellungen zu konvertieren – manchmal ganz einfach und direkt. Und das ist das Ende der
Lektion, in der es um Kanäle ging. Wir haben besprochen, was sie sind, und uns einige grundlegende Beispiele angesehen. Wir haben drei Möglichkeiten besprochen, wie Kanäle dargestellt werden können,
und wir haben uns in einige technische Details vertieft, die die Äquivalenz dieser Darstellungen belegen. Ich
hoffe, du bist bei der nächsten Lektion dabei, in der es um Messungen in der allgemeinen Formulierung der Quanteninformation geht. Tschüss bis dann!